and like managing because a lot of times  girls want a guy that makes a lot of  money because they want a lifestyle but  they don't know how to be like Frugal  and she was saying that she could raise  kids on like 500 bucks a month or less  all right Andrew Tate said that too and  I was like hey what well think about it  like what do you need you need food  private school okay but that's that's a  lifestyle Choice yeah yeah so that like  goes back to like even just like basic  [ __ ] I feel like a kid is going to cost  way more than that yeah I mean if you if  you wanted to but if you wanted to yeah  but I don't want to give my kid a  [ __ ] Somalian upbringing here in  Beverly Hills yeah I mean that's fine  but the cost to raise a kid out here  like average kid like even if you're not  like on some rich [ __ ] at all like I  don't know yeah  no